welcome back your insurance agency the
sponsors of this segment are back with
care more Health to discuss what you
should be looking for when considering a
primary care provider
welcome back to your insurance agency
our special guest today is Dr wadwin
with the care Moore which is the medical
director officer Fort CareMore one of
the things we wanted to talk to you
about today is in the sea of many
choices what makes your provider Network
different and so I welcome Dr wadrat to
share with us what's unique about care
more so caramel health is an advanced
Primary Care Group we're a group of
clinicians that are in your
neighborhoods providing life-changing
care to our Las Vegas residents
especially those with chronic and
complex conditions you know we at care
more believe in whole person care often
taking care of patients involves not
only addressing their medical needs but
also their social and emotional needs
our Healthy Start are off new patient
appointments are designed just for that
they're about 60 Minutes long and it
allows your provider to have enough time
to get to know you do a comprehensive
head to toe assessment we can then
identify your medical needs as well as a
social and emotional needs and then we
can partner with our patients to develop
personalized care plants to address the
issues that are most important to them
with many complex issues that we have to
serve our clients that ultimately become
your patients it's a very difficult job
to sometimes do so what services do you
provide that really set you apart from
the other medical groups absolutely
that's such a great question Chris
the right place at the right time our
patients all have access to care more
anytime this is a special number in
which they can call a clinician and have
access to a collision clinician 24 7 365
days a year in cases of an emergency we
also provide same-day access and walk-in
appointments for all of our patients at
any of our three locations across the
valley in addition if it's you're unable
to get to us we have a team of mobile
providers that can come to your house
and assess your condition and then
provide and address your concerns we
also provide virtual access to our
patients so at care mall we want to meet
our patients when and where they need
care I truly believe it takes a village
day care of patients so with our
Advanced Primary Care model our patients
have access not only to the primary care
physician but also an interdisciplinary
team which includes chronic disease
practitioners social workers case
managers community health workers
sub-specialty support such as Behavioral
Health clinical pharmacists Podiatry
this allows us to provide whole person
care that we believe is so important for
our patients one of the things that
makes care more uniquely different is
the care model if you notice I didn't
mentioned doctors because doctors may
come and go but the value of care or the
care model Still Remains the Same care
more does retain doctors too but
sometimes they do come and go and that's
important to know that you have a care
model that's going to be there for you
to take care of you for the long-term
needs we appreciate our partnership with
care more it's nice to have something
behind us Brokers that is there to help
support the people we serve best we have
well-trained Brokers ready to serve you
to help you find a good care more
location and doctor to work with
thank you to your insurance agency for
sponsoring the segment you can find them
at the Galleria and Meadows Malls call
the CareMore call line at
702-487-8869 or visit
yianv.com CareMore for more information